all right folks this is the moment we've
all been waiting for and that is a big
budget blockbuster movie going
experience theatrically released
at all like we'll take anything at this
point turns out it's a trailer for
godzilla versus kong a battle royale
that'll make the 2020 election look like
a game of patty cake that's also coming
to hbo max i'm glad there was a
compromise there i just feel like some
movies you got to see in this grand
scale
so i'm glad it's coming to theaters and
also hbo max for people who
like i there are no theaters in my state
i don't even know if
are there any at all nationally i don't
know it's like
you notice the things of king kong but
you know it's different they're changing
it up because it
is a different telling of the story of
kong i mean he's in shackles he's being
brought over on the boat not to
necessarily make money on broadway and
now
godzilla's freaking out for some odd
reason like godzilla's just kind of
flipped and
turned into a villain we don't know why
there's something happening in there and
i'm sure someone had the conversation of
like hey
you guys ever seen pacific rim we can
build a big robot in fact we can make it
look like godzilla we'll call it
mechagodzilla we'll fight godzilla all
right that sounds way too expensive fine
i know a guy we'll bring him over in
which case kong's like i'll
only talk to the kid kong seems to be
like i don't like people but the kid's
all right it looks like kong's like all
right the fact that the kid asked and
godzilla wrecked my boat all right i'll
punch him in the face [ __ ] you godzilla
it's a fight that's happened before on
screen it'll happen again on screen it's
one of those fights that's just
inevitable i will say godzilla
has better ranged attacks so hopefully
for kong he doesn't fight godzilla
online otherwise godzilla's just gonna
zone him the entire time like a big
douche you know what i'm talking about
but i mean you know we can count on
another city to destroy because this is
kind of what happens
cities fall to the clash of these titans
and it's like they're like hey look at
this this place looks nice all right
let's just [ __ ] this place up for good
measure we'll even do the thanos and
thor's axe thing from avengers infinity
war it's what i thought of anyway i
don't know why i did i did
difference is kong went for the head my
concern with this movie the whole thing
is really the human element i think
that's a reasonable concern because
it's a balancing act you know it's a
balance that this movie has to reach
in using humans to take the audience
through it but
also not having these humans who are
definitely not as interesting as
monsters clashing
overshadowing the monsters and
detracting from that experience so i
hope they strike the balance you know
because
in a world where godzilla's freaking out
there's gonna be this whole human
investigation of like oh well
why is godzilla freaking out he was so
nice before
is he experiencing godzilla pawn far
he's just
thermal waving people for no reason
apparently so yeah i thought the trailer
for godzilla versus kong
solid trailer you see godzilla wait for
it fighting kong
that's what we're here for doesn't hurt
that it's just it's that trailer that's
the blockbuster
feeling of a theatrically released film
though
a lot of us probably won't be able to
see it theatrically maybe you will maybe
i will
i don't know the future is not written
but it gives you that
feel in a trailer that i haven't
experienced in a very long time
it's a feeling i miss so i'm glad even
if the movie gets delayed until 2028 or
whatever
glad i got that feeling with this
trailer also see you using optimus
prime's words here or it's will fall not
shall play the smart you change one word
to avoid copyright infringement you
don't want to go toe-to-toe with those
cybertron lawyers
good on you all right so the trailer for
godzilla vs kong have you seen it why
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you